une reprise prochaine salut ma chérie si
je te dis mon coeur si je te dis dieu
pourquoi sa santé si je te dis pierre
est ce que tu te rappelles parce que il
ya dj marky qui nous a rejoint
[Applaudissements]
le dos
je te plait merci contre assez pressé il
ya star trek car il est chez machin ou
jean surprise pour toi est ce que tu te
rappelles de gens de pierre dejean ou de
jean pierre boulât c'est pierre serre
oui oui il y en a plein je me rappelle
ça faisait bien longtemps
c'est c est ce que tu te rappelles d'un
slot t'annoncer avec un pire l'an 2000 à
trappes où la foule à elle bondi le
dossier de ce les pierres d'assises doit
dire oui
non mais tu avais 15 ans oui tu t'en
rappelles ou pas et ben pierre et là ce
soir
regardez moba fait leur entrée
maintenant tout le monde a compris entre
autres et pierre pierre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est alors ça y va mais dans ces
caméras souple et chirac me pierre est
ce que tu es content de voir pierre je
serre les dents sion sans pourtant
jamais cessé
je sais que j'avais danse et un sous
ensemble enfin pierre veya louent des
chalets mais si vous voulez refaire ce
chiot pour nous ce soir
qu'est ce qui va nous mettre c'était sur
quoi le slogan c'est sûr aimé ce déchet
il a eu à lost ou pas mais arrête le
titre venait mois shy'm les poneys
lapierre la mettez vous la mettez vous
le mettez vous là et c'est pas possible
faut prévient pour sa part de choses
à quoi ça vous fait plaisir de le revoir
bah oui mais comme ça ici c'était un peu
compliqué 10g qu'avec valérie tout ça
revenait la non vous êtes ou doit il se
sent isolé dans m'arrêter là c'est vrai
que ça ne serait que moi je vois que
vous êtes allez vous encore c'est dur à
dire mais aussi mettez vous là bas alors
les cherry est ce que vous voulez nous
refaire le slot et mais comme avant ça
m'a bien sûr je voudrais demander à
didier marty de bien vouloir mettre nous
remettre nos maîtres le saut paniquer
mais c'est cette loi s'est perdu en
pensant qu alice
[Musique]
à
pas parce que je
ici
si on fait pareil
pierre berecz à l'arrêter 2000 et shine
5 je vous sens hilaire une wii de revoir
pierre il parle parce que moi je veux
dire quelque chose tellement hâte en
civil par non il avait alors pire c'est
que votre monde familier pierre il
s'appelle comment est ce que tu te
rappelles de son nom de famille à pierre
mondy mais vous êtes sûr je vais te
buter était chez lui mais c'est quoi la
paire colada et mélanie vont rester là
bas
eh ben je vais vous mettez pas la
sublime est évident c'est avec moi non
alors mettez-vous la batterie
mettez vous là bas allaient nous mettez
vous mettez pas la table si vous ne
croyez pas débuté hier que la saison
vient alors allez-y relancer
[Musique]
mais sortez d'apple et mettez vous la
mettez vous demande rien mais tu voudras
jouent leur carrière sur play qui allie
mettez-vous devant voilà vous êtes avec
martine itasse on marty voilà et cheryl
et s'il vous plaît martic escales et
cyril je voulais dire quelque chose qui
moi ça fait pas mystère il al'air
chocolat
[Applaudissements]
sa vision du métier